okay today I'm going to talk to you
about extracting metals we use metals
all the time in everyday life but in
order to use the metal we need to
extract it first the structure and just
means getting it by itself now there's a
few metals that are so unreactive that
they just find uncombined in the earth
so this is a reactivity series here the
most reactive metals at the top the
least rates at the bottom I've done
carbon in capital letters because it's
the only one on here which isn't a metal
so these ones at the bottom are so
unreactive that we can just find them
uncombined in the earth if we dig them
up this means that if I dug up gold it
would just literally be a chunk of gold
rather than having to find it and take
it out I think in order to understand
that we need to know what an orange so
basically and all is when a metal is
found in the ground reacted with oxygen
so in a compound with oxygen so an
example is something called bauxite
which is aluminium ore so it's al2o3
so bauxite is is yes something called an
ore in order to use aluminium we have to
extract it which means we need to remove
it from the oxygen so this there's two
different ways of extraction that we
need to know about the first one these
ones I've kind of highlighted in green
we can we can extract these metals by
using reduction with reduction using
carbon now the reason why we can reduce
these using carbon is because there are
below carbon in the reactivity series
anything above carbon we can not use
this method for so how does it work
let's imagine we have iron ore so iron
or also known as hematite is iron oxide
again iron in a compound with oxygen
what we need to do is we need to heat it
in a blast furnace with carbon when we
do this we can see we have a
displacement reaction
happening because carbon is more
reactive than iron it's higher than it
on the reactivity series the carbon will
replace the iron this is called a
displacement reaction so the iron will
be left all by itself remember that's
what we're trying to achieve we're
trying to extract the metal and get it
all by itself so I can use it so now
I've got the iron and also now have the
carbon combining with the oxygen and the
gas formed is going to be carbon dioxide
now like I said this can't happen with
all of the different metals or metal
ores from the reactivity series if I
have a look for example at an iminium
bauxite it's more reactive than carbon
so if I try to do this there would be no
reaction at all so for these method of
these metals we need a different
strategy for these metals that are more
reactive than carbon we need to use
electrolysis now electrolysis think
about the word electro means using
electricity and lysis means splitting or
separating so electrolysis just means
separating using electricity so let's
have a quick look at how this works so
what I'm drawing right now is two
different electrodes a positive
electrode and a negative electrode
positive electrode is called the anode
and the negative electrode is called the
cathode so what we need to do the very
first thing we need to do let's say if
I'm trying to extract aluminium from its
or book site first thing I need to do is
melt the bauxite now this will require a
really really high temperature so it's
very expensive to get it to melt to
create enough energy and heat to melt
bauxite now the ions that I'd have in
solution are al 3 plus ions so aluminium
ions and oxide ions as well now with in
electrolysis the remember opposites
attract so these positive aluminium ions
are going to go to the cathode and these
negative oxide ions are going to go to
the anode so what I'm just going to show
real briefly is the reaction that's
going to happen here because at the
anode we have our oxygens are going to
form oxygen and we're going to actually
lose lose some electrons here and at the
cathode we start off with our aluminium
ions and they are going to be reduced
they're going to gain electrons to form
aluminium now I've gone through that bit
really briefly if you want to learn more
about this please watch the video about
electrolysis now the big problems
associate with electrolysis is it's
extremely expensive the reason why it's
expensive is we need to melt all of this
melt all of the bauxite first so
requires loads and loads of energy and
there's a lot of electricity is required
to be passed through the electrodes in
order to in order to cause the movement
of these islands so it's extremely
expensive and uses lots of electricity
but if the if the if the metal or if the
metal is more reactive than carbon we
don't really have a choice because we
can't extract it using reduction with
carbon so that's how we extract metals
the least reactive ones are on combined
elements the ones that are less reactive
the but are in an or so left directed to
the carbon would have found in law we
can extract using reduction using carbon
and at those ores those metal ores that
are more reactive than carbon we have to
use electrolysis thank you